مراسل العربيه في تركيا بان احزاب
المعارضه التركيه ستعلن عن مرشحها المشترك
لرئاسه يوم الاثنين ياتي ذلك بعد ان جدد
خمسه زعماء بقينا في تحالف المعارضه
التركيه التزامهم بمبادئه التاسيسيه بعد
ان انسحمت سحبت زعامه الحزب الصالح من
التحالف اثر خلاف حول المرشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه حيث اشار البيان الخماسي الى ان
ائتلاف مصمم الهذا الائتلاف مصمم على
مواصله عمله في نفس الاتجاه تمشيا مع
مبادئه واهدافه التاسيسيه في السياق ذاته
اكد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان حزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم وحليفه القومي
يتمسكان بمواصله مسارهما بعد انقسام تحالف
المعارضه حول مرشحه للرئاسه في الانتخابات
العامه المقرره في منتصف مايو المقبل وقال
انهم كانوا يتوقعون حدوث ذلك قبل الشهور
لكن حزب حدد هدفه وهو ماض في العمل على
خريطه الطريق الخاصه بهم من جه اته اشار
زعيم المعارضه كمال كليتش دور اوغلو الى
ان احزاب اخرى ستنضم للتحالف في اعقاب
انسحاب حزب الجيد ثاني اكبر احزاب
المعارضه في البلاد من تكتل الطاوله
السداسيه
طبعا لا شك ان زلزال تركيا سيخلف ارتدادات
في المشهد السياسي بالبلاد قبل شهرين من
الانتخابات الحاسمه حيث تريد غالبيه
الاطراف توظيف ما حصل في حملاتها
الانتخابيه ويبدو حزب العداله والتنميه
ورئيسه اردوغان في عين العاصفه لا سيما
بعد الحديث عن قصور في عمليات الاستجابه
خلال الايام الاولى لوقوع الكارثه